[Music]  wait up wait up  what are you doing with all this junk  keeps me busy  another long night of crime and violence  some say it's only a matter of time  before the city implodes  i think we're finished here come on beat  it  i found him  samaritan  samaritan died 25 years ago  that's what they say  you think you live across from a  superhero do you have a therapist kid  good  samaritan's dead  i pick up garbage for a living  samaritan cleaned up the streets  you mind your business on my mind  are you okay  oh cool  how strong are you  kind of struggling that once was things  start to fall apart when you stop  carrying  i stopped caring a long time ago  how come you hate who you are  for some people it's too late to change  the damage they've done  he's hiding something  i want him dead  really  [Music]  the things you buried tend to haunt you  why did you disappear  [Music]  hey old man  try this  [Music]  you